okay let's get going
then so welcome to today's lecture and
we continue where we have left
so as in the last several lectures we
are working with operator learning and
the setup is the same so you have been
given an abstract PD and associated with
that PD is a solution operator which
Maps a function space to the function
space in other words it takes the inputs
coefficient and forces in this
particular case and it returns back the
solution so this is as as before and
since the problem is essential in infin
dimensional problem we have to sort of
think about how to represent it
discretly in other words we have to
think about what is this continuous
discret this was the key concept that
that we wanted to think about and in
this context we introduced Reno uh
representation equivalent neural
operator and the idea let me repeat it
again because it's very important
is that uh you will never be able to
have or work with this operator directly
even if you want to learn it so what you
have to do is to have some finite
dimensional representations
approximations of this operator which is
given here and the link between the two
is what really defines operator learning
and in particular if this diagram
commutes that is uh whether you work
directly at the continuous level or
whether you start at the continuous
function space go to a grid discrete
operate at the level of the grid this is
the discrete operation CNN whatever and
then you go back if this entire thing is
exactly the same this diagram commutes
so you have no aliasing error so this is
uh the aliasing the difference between
the two is the aliasing error here and
as long as there is no aliasing you can
do some genuine Bona Bona operator
learning right so this is this is the
setup that we in and we saw that CNN's
they broke this and in the last lecture
most of the time was spent with fno for
neural operators and let me just uh
recall what foral operators are so that
it gets imprinted uh into you so we have
uh some input a here and some output
which is U similar to what we had in
last slide and now what you do is you
have different layers in particular this
is a lifting right just to recall so
this is lifting where you simply add
more features add channels so that uh
instead of working with physical
variables density pressure and so on and
so forth you work with some sort of
representations some more uh abstract
representations of these features and
once you have lifted you have added more
channels you have to also project them
so this is the projection so these two
are typically linear layers or you could
use MLPs here this is the choice is wide
but but all the action takes place in
the processing which is done through
this what are called f LS and this is
the cartoon of a f LS so you start with
a function you go to Fier Fier transform
it so if you on a grid then you can do
it fast with the fast forier transform
and then you truncate you truncate the
number of fua modes and this is and do
some fua multiplier so this is the
learnable parameter and two things
happening first of all you transform the
for coefficients in some some way and
then what you do is you also truncate
them right so instead of having four you
just take two of these harmonics so as
you can see in this picture that's
that's a representation you go back to
physical space through the inverse fora
transform also through fft and then
you're going to process it with you keep
some of the signal so some of the signal
is kept through the what is called the
residual connection good for training
and it has some other retain some
spatial information and so on and then
you apply the nonlinearity pointwise and
you do it over and over again so this is
uh f o but as I explained at the end of
the last
lecture there is an issue with f in the
sense that uh there is there is an issue
in the sense that activation function
this uh the nonlinearity there that sort
of broke this commutative diagram it
broke this because at the end of the day
what happens is that there has to be a
neat correspondence between these spaces
and if you take these as spaces of band
limited functions and you apply a
nonlinearity then that equivalence is
broken and once that equivalence is
broken then you end up with situations
like this the example that I showed you
last time of random assignment where you
can train on a grid um and you get very
very good results with both CNN and fno
but as soon as you slightly change this
was an extreme example as soon as you
slightly change the let's say the
representation the resolution uh even by
one point then you start getting large
errors right both for CNO and fnn uh fno
and CNN and uh this is the regime where
you don't have uh the neist condition
satisfied so you don't expect that this
they'll always be Al because there
simply not enough uh Point density there
okay so this showed us that we have to
sort of continue the search and this is
reinforced when you take practical
examples realistic examples so this is
again back to nav Stokes
uh which is more or less the main
equation that we have in the course and
this is the operator it takes a velocity
field and it turns out another velocity
field and we sort of visualize it
through the verticity so you can see
that there is this initial shear and
that leads to the shedding of vertices
right so this is the this is the picture
and if you take a fno what happens in
this particular case is that the trading
resolution is here and then the test
resolution you have uh at different
grades so when you increase the
resolution you do get small errors uh
because these high frequencies are
probably small but when you reduce the
resolution while still keeping within
the nequis barrier you get large errors
so this is again the fact that it is not
R so there is no representation
equivalence you end up uh there are aing
errors and this will affect the quality
of the solution it depends on the
problem sometimes you know the high
frequencies are really damped out in a
problem in some other cases high
frequencies remain so there is there is
the issue right so the question is we
need to challenge the the challenge here
is we need to design an operator a
neural operator that Sid steps this
issue that is able to do this processing
between different grades that can
operate at any resolution and so on that
learns the actual operator instead of
just a map that takes a particular
finite dimensional representation and
turns out another fin dimensional
representation so how do we do that so
in today's lecture as well as in the
next lecture we will see some examples
so next lectures we'll see some
examples and uh for today's lecture we
take some inspiration from traditional
numerical methods so as I said in the
very beginning of the course um perhaps
in the second or the third lecture that
there is a wide sort of menu of uh
numerical methods they go by different
names so you have finite differences you
have finite volumes finite elements and
spectral methods and many others some of
you have seen this methods in your
scientific Computing computational
science or numerical analysis courses
numerical methods courses so there are
wide variety of these methods and in
some sense these methods also have to
work in the same Paradigm right because
there whether you approximate the
solution operator through machine
learning or whether you approximate the
solution operator through numerical
modeling at the end of the day you are
approximating an operator so you are
essentially dealing with an infinite
dimensional problem right they're also
the inputs for instance if I wanted to
solve this with a spectral method which
generates the ground truth you can see
that I start with I have to project it
onto some grid onto some basis process
with the basis and then proceed so how
is this
done so here is again the same figure
which comes again and again and again
with similar notation with slight slight
vertion here for a reason as you'll see
so in fact numerical methods can very
much be represented or interpreted in
exactly the same Paradigm as the machine
learning methods that I just showed you
so again you have done operator so I
don't know why this is a this an old
name instead of G I said a to
distinguish between learning and
numerical approximation but essentially
at the end of the day you want to
approximate this operator out here
capital G or script g calligraphic g
which takes H I'm sorry about um mistake
here it's it should be script of course
script x x and script y but again what
do they do these methods all rely on the
same principle that you start with an
infinite dimensional function space you
project it down to Something in finite
Dimensions you work in finite
dimensional spaces um time stepping or
whatever solving inverting a stiffness
Matrix uh whatever is the necessity and
then you go back to infinite Dimensions
through some interpolation right so if
you think of finite differences now
those of you know I think I introduced
the finite difference methods for
instance quickly if you take the heat
equation so U minus uu XX equal to Z and
you take a grid in space and
time so something like this and then to
calculate unu n + 1 at some point J this
was unu n what was
the so it was delta T by Delta x² of U
and a - 1 + 1 - 2 delta T by Delta x^ 2
of U and J + Delta by Delta x^ 2 of u j
+
1 right so this was the this was the
picture we had done this in one of the
lectures so I take these three points
and then I evolve to the next time step
and I keep on doing this right so this
bit here which is what I call as
approximator this is the numerical
scheme we have no learning there but uh
uh so this replaces the role of what
where is the picture this replaces the
role of this guy here this G here okay
it replaces that because it's not based
on it's based on first principle physics
you have access to the equation so you
can solve it uh similarly and then once
you have the point values then you can
always use a polinomial interpol right
some sort of interpolation so this part
is this is the interpolator this is the
encoding which is just point values
point viations and this is some
processing similarly for find elements
for those who know this it's exactly the
same principle now what you do is that
you have a basis which is consisting of
finite element functions and then you
take these Point values which are node
values these are the coresponding
coefficients you do some work with them
for instance invert a mass sorry a
stiffness Matrix and then you go back to
infinite Dimensions through the finite
element of the Gan basis same principle
for finite volume spectral you do this
for Foria coefficients so what what is
the what's the objective or what's the
bottom line here that when you have an
infinite dimensional problem you reduce
it to finite Dimensions this could be
coefficients of a basis in the most
General case even Point values are the
coefficients with respect to the sync
bases that I introduced in one of the
last lectures right so all of this is
essentially so this part here this e is
some sort of a
basis projection right
and R here the Reconstruction is a
basis
reconstruction so if you have been given
a basis whether it is sync or finite
element basis or P wise constants or F
Fier is the basis for spectral methods P
wise constants are the basis for find
element methods find volume methods and
so on and so forth right so one you
project down to a basis and on the other
side you just take the coefficients and
then you just form the basis expansion
that's why it's called a basis
reconstruction all numerical methods
somehow fall into this uh let's say this
scheme right and in between this is
where the physics takes place right so
you you sort of have a discrete version
of the equation and you are going to
propagate the discrete version of the
equation but all the time you're going
to work with these spasis coefficients
right and this is not what we did for
instance with f with fno o this was a
little bit more complicated that we
where is the fno picture now that we we
did some extraction but at the same time
we kept some elements of it we were
learning it as some sort of function to
function rather than directly working
with some basis elements and it turns
out that you can sort of imitate this uh
scheme this picture that I just
presented here and you can end up with a
class of machine learning or operator
learning methods which are introduced in
the next slide so in some
generality these methods can be termed
as spectral neural operators
this is this is a general name but um
it's it's a good name and the idea is
exactly as before right so just like in
numerical methods we drop things down to
a basis and we project them up using the
basis in between instead of having a
numerical method I strictly work with um
some DNN right some sort of a it could
be MLPs it could be CNN it does not
really matter mostly these are MLPs
because now
they can't be CNN because CNN are based
on functions or on pixels and so on
these are just based on some sort of
MLPs so let me repeat there is some some
math here which is fairly
straightforward uh in some particular
example but let me just give you a very
simple idea so you have some
input so this input is going to be let's
say a that is how I express my input I
express it in terms some some basis
AJ SJ right x i is some bases that I'm
going to choose now I have access to the
vector AJ so this is J from 1 to L and I
take a neural network let me call it as
l i take this AJ and I churn out some
UJ u j j from 1 to M it could be the
number so you directly work with the
bases you you forget all this notion of
space that we have all this notion that
these are parts of a function you just
just work with these discrete
coefficients and you process them okay
by your DNN and finally in the last step
you just take your U as an approximation
of this UJ SJ again let's say that the
basis in the input and output is exactly
the same so this is what is being done
in the spectral neural operators okay
and now based on what basis you choose
you get different classes of functions
remember that FN is not exactly in this
framework because it does not
necessarily always have this represent
presentation you still have a notion of
space and similarly for CNN you still
have a notion of space here you remove
that completely you work with these
objects as discrete objects and you
expect that somehow this information
that these come from a function is
represented in the fact that the fio
coefficients for example are going to
Decay right if you have a smooth
function they're going to have a certain
Decay okay so is this is the scheme
clear and see what what is the
difference between what we did before
before we were sort of processing an
entire image or an entire pixel here
we're not doing that we're taking a
function an image and we're taking first
24 year coefficients we are sort of
processing them into a neural network we
are getting another 20 coefficients and
then we are coming back okay and that is
dramatically different from what not
dramatically but there is a subtle
difference from what we did before which
was that we operated the image by itself
and did some processing with it now as
long as a particular realization which
was done by the these people here it
takes and you'll see that there is there
are some good things and bad things with
is with fora basis that's the simplest
that you can think of right so in
particular if your periodic um problems
periodic problems it's very natural to
express them in terms of science and cos
signs which is a fora basis so of course
you need to work with pan limited
functions because otherwise the space is
too big to carry out this program and
then this construction here so because
we are always with for coefficients I
take it complex Valu but in practice we
take it real value right the imaginary
parts are going to cancel out so what is
the idea it's precisely what I said here
so this T of S K and S K Prime is just
operators which tell you that you can
drop things down to a basis and
reconstruct them up this as simple as
that okay but the idea is of course this
is a Reno now because uh here everything
is done in a finite dimensional way
means there is no notion so even if you
have so the simplest way to imagine it
is that if you have two different grides
okay it does not really matter because I
take function from one grid and I simply
project it onto some fixed number of
foror coefficients and I take function
from another grid and I project it onto
the same number of foror coefficients
and then I do the processing and I do
the Reconstruction so to me it does not
really matter whether the function is on
a fine grade or a course grid as long as
I don't change my number of variables
right of course the point is just
imagine that you have a function on a
COR scrip and you project it onto 204a
coefficients and maybe perhaps this is a
good representation of the function on
the other hand when you have it on a
finer grid you might want to project it
into more F coefficients but you don't
have that flexibility here
yes it is uh not very different in some
sense but here the parameters you'll see
in a in a second that you can extend
this to to cover the non is not strictly
parametric because earlier you you did
not in a way you were sort of constrain
to you you could never use a function in
some sense right so this this adds one
additional layer now all that it tells
you is that you start with a function
and you project it onto some fixed
number of parameters earlier you were
directly working with that so you did
not even have this first step here so
this part was redundant you didn't even
need it so you have one additional lay
but in in some sense you hit the nail on
the head because It suffers from some of
the same problems that a parametric
representation has right so I'm not
saying that all the problems are going
to be solved by this but this is one
particular way where you solve one
problem which is that you have different
information on the grid you don't care
because you're projecting on to a finite
basis of course this is very limiting
because it tells you that this a
straight jacket that we have to wrap
around ourselves which is uh which is
not nice so there is a generalization
which is uh or a variant you could also
I should have used the word
generalization and this was one of the
first operator learning architectures
that was introduced even though the name
was not yet there it is called uh Deets
uh some of you might have seen that so
this actually comes from the '90s by by
two Chinese computer scientists in the
'90s but the modern version of it is 3
four years old like everything else so
the idea here is so here the problem was
that we somehow have to supply the basis
right some expert knowledge is required
we say okay these are periodic functions
so P basis or these are some other
structures or chv CH bases or these are
on a sphere sperical harmonics mean this
is sort of some expert knowledge that we
are going to use so what these people
argued is that what if we also learn the
basis and not just uh it seems to be a
smarter thing to do to have that kind of
a generality to be able to learn the
basis and this this is what ponet does
let me fairly quickly sort of explain
that so that you learn some of the
history of the topic also you'll see
that this is it has its problems but uh
you see where it comes from so it's
exactly the same picture as before maybe
I show it in terms of U so there are two
things here there are two elements um
one is of course coefficients let me try
to summarize them so these are
coefficients as before
okay but this guy here the
t is roughly approximating a basis in
fact it has even as a name it's called a
trunk
net and this on the other hand the
coefficients is a branch net so at first
side it looks like a very very
complicated construction but in reality
it's a fairly simple idea except that
you now have a learnable basis so you
first from the data that you have you of
course learn learn a basis first or
together you learn a basis as well as
you learn the coefficients okay so both
things are done simultaneously and of
course this you can imagine it seems
like a smart idea but it has its issues
because you have to learn probably too
much so what is the basic idea let me
explain it in the perhaps in this
picture here so sorry for the confusing
notation because I copied the picture
from somewhere so this is your input now
it's not called a anymore it's called
you but nevertheless doesn't really
matter so the encoding the is given by
Point wise values so this is uh point I
think I say it here sensor evaluations
so these are Point
values so theistic is that you have some
temperature let's say this is your input
temperature and you want to predict the
temperature after 6 hours right as we do
in a weather forecast so you're going to
observe this temperature by using some
sensors which are precisely Point values
of the temperature now these Point
values are allowed to in this particular
case they not even lie on a grid they're
even allowed to be random points that's
not that's not a problem however for
different realizations these have to be
the same kind of uh sensors or the same
points okay so Point evaluation so this
extracts so the these coefficients the
input coefficients are extracted just by
Point evaluations like we did with
convolutions it's exactly the same same
principle except here the flexibility is
that you are allowed to have arbitrary
collection of points as long as you keep
the same sensors for every like you
measure the temperature now at the same
sensors in six hours at the same sensors
then 12 hours at the same sensors and so
on so this is somehow some restriction
here but nevertheless that's the first
thing so and you're going to process
this right you're taking these
coefficients just like we did with
spectral neural operators we are going
to throw them into a neural network and
this neural network CHS out some output
coefficients so these are the output
coefficient
exactly as before there is nothing
nothing special about this right but now
what about the basis we also have to
learn the bases in which we are going to
represent the function right so the
bases are these TOS these represent the
bases how are we going to learn them so
remember that the basis is now a
function each basis function is a
function so let me isolate a single one
of them let me call it a St K so this is
a function of y y belongs to D the
domain on which all the action is taking
in place so of course the input to this
function is going to be the coordinate
at which you're going to evaluate the
function right we are we are going to
form a function so of course the
function for instance let's do a picture
here let's say that your domain is 01
this is D 01 and I need to I have a
function some sort of a function that
I'm going to evaluate so what I do is as
input I give any value and as output I
extract the value right and you have to
do it for M basis functions 10 or 100 or
whatever depending on the problem that
you have you do that so you have some
basis function and this is going to be a
general function right this need not be
a sign or a cosine or a chv polinomial
or rational function or whatever now
this is where the universality of neural
networks comes in right so in one of the
lectures you saw that neural networks
are Universal in the sense that any
continuous function any measurable
function any integrable function can be
approximated by neural networks so the
idea of these people was okay let's do
these to be neural networks so each of
these guys are DNN or MLPs let's say so
each okay it could be more there could
be more structure this could be CNN and
so on and so forth but in this case the
simplest is to have it this is an MLP so
this is a multi-layer perceptron so you
have now M neural networks which are
going to represent your bases you're
going to have n neural net or M neural
networks which are going to represent
your coefficients right and the these
are sort of running parallel to each
other they have different semantics they
have different heuristics there there is
a difference between them so this
approximation now is entirely done in
terms of the coefficients that we are
extracting here just like we did in SN
and then the Reconstruction is done in
terms of these two bases uh of these
bases functions so remember that there
are two layers that are happening here
so one the coefficient is being
approximated but the basis in which it
is going to be expressed is also being
learned at the same time from data okay
so both things uh and this is uh this is
a feasible problem it's not an
infeasible problem that is that is what
is going on right and at the end of the
day you form the sum it would be an aine
sum and then you have at least uh neural
operator it's something that takes into
account functions so the inputs you take
the point values you use them in the
coefficients simultaneously you are
learning a basis so for different
problems of course you will have
different BAS right so seems like a very
smart idea it's it's not very unrelated
to some things if people know some
statistics the basics of Statistics
there is something called PCA principal
component analysis so it is similar so
in principal component analysis also you
learn bases and these bases are based on
the principal components on the
statistical structure of the data that
you are given so it's a little bit like
that instead of taking the principle
components you take neural networks
because in principle neural networks can
approximate anything so the the the
construction itself is very neat in that
sense that you have a learnable basis
and you have learnable coefficients
where these PES are going to be
expressed are there any questions about
this everyone
yes the there is a difference because uh
pcnet is a more a little bit more in
this spirit that uh yeah I can also
describe it quickly so what is PCA PCA
is that if you are I'm not going into
too much of detail here right because I
need to write down a lot of stuff for
that in particular I need to introduce
what is called the kovarian operator The
kovarian Matrix because the PCA is
nothing but igen functions or I values
of this karian Matrix so think at a very
abstract level what PCA does is that it
looks at the data that you have okay it
just looks at the data that you have and
it extracts the basis from the structure
of the data it does not do any
processing of the data it extracts the
basis from the structure of the data and
this is so you have these inputs here
UI or AI I don't know how how I express
them and then there are I don't know
thousand data pairs let's say thousand
uh examples let let's do a concrete
example here and then I can explain so
let's say thousand examples of these
guys right these kind of sheer initial
sheer um layers and then what you do is
that you put them all together and then
you compute their covariant this is a
this a matrix there are some efficient
algorithms are available on how to
extract it values so you EXT and it
vectors and then you rewrite this uh in
terms so any input a is now written in
terms of some AI or AJ PJ and this PJ is
this PCA basis for the input okay and
you do the same at the level of the
output you just look at the data and you
are extracting uh the output PCA basis
also me the these are pre and pro post
or pre-processing in some sense right
you have been given the data and you
form a basis if you get new data there
are also algorithms on how to augment
this how to augment the bases and so on
and then in between so you have
similarly for the output you would have
uh I don't know let's say U is the
output so it's some UJ SJ right and then
you need a link between this AJ and this
UJ
and this is provided by a neural network
okay so in some sense you are also using
learning but you just use statistical
learning uh at the input of the output
and in between you use neuron networks
so there is a difference here in the
sense that you're not simultaneously
learning the basis as well as the and
now here there's a different basis for
the input and output potentially whereas
with Depon net you're trying to learn
the same basis okay so these are somehow
intrinsically connected to each other
because of course I can approximate my
PCA functions by neural networks or I
can also approximate my new networks by
PCA function so they they're all somehow
close to each other in spirit they are
sort of as I said Sly different from
what we did before which was that we
directly worked with the image or we
directly worked with the function the
sort of the spatial structure of the
function here you just take the function
you put it into a bag of coefficients
and these coefficients they they sort of
implicitly represent the function you
process them and you come back okay so
you are just doing all the processing at
a at a very Parallel level in some sense
so is that clear okay so now what is the
good thing about it is that of course
you can you can train it like you you
trained fno and so on and in fact people
have done that that's the good and the
good thing is that these are also Renos
because again for the same principle
because now you are always restricting
things into
some finite dimensional space
irrespective of what grid that you're
looking for because now it's just a
fixed set of sensors so of course
there's no issue there and in fact there
are some conditions for instance this
even though you are sort of training it
as a basis with the PCA there's no
ambiguity whatsoever if you have
infinite number of samples then it will
be a basis that is a guarantee there
here on the other hand there is no such
guarantee you're just trying to have the
semantics of a basis
and you think that your learning problem
is going to provide you a basis it need
not be a basis okay it need not be a
basis these functions actually they look
nothing like a basis in practice but it
did not be a basis and in fact that is
not necessary the theory is such that
it's enough to work with what are called
frames uh these are not basis functions
but frames and then of course uh because
you are doing it on non-uniform grids
random grids and so on there is some
aliasing error coming from there you
know so if you do it on uniform grid
there is no aliasing error because the
newquist conditions are satisfied and as
I kept on saying that this need not be a
basis okay because there is no reason
why we sort of impose orthogonality and
so on this is objective but in the
training process we are not doing it we
could impose it in the training process
we could say that there is some
orthogonality condition that we are
going to be impose but that is uh not
fair because you don't know exactly what
nor or what in a product that you're
going to use right from the data how are
you going to know what is the right in a
product to use so it's it's not is not
that clean in that sense you see so this
is just this is an option that is always
available to us and in fact it's a it's
a baseline in some
sense but it has it does what it does in
that in this sense right that it is a
Reno it is able to represent data from
different grids simply because it
projects them onto some particular bag
and then processes them so in that way
there is some
cheating that is doing uh that is taking
place but what is the what is the issue
with this then so is this uh clear what
is the construction here so what's the
issue do they work in practice some
cases of course uh they work in practice
but however I'll give you a very simple
example where some of the problems of
this approach comes out so the simplest
non linear equation that you PD that you
can think of is what is called the
burgus equation so this is a burgus
equation
uh it was invented by Burgers as a model
for Navia
Stokes didn't turn out to be such a good
model but uh it is what it is so the
equation itself is given by this form in
it's a it's a 1D equation space time
sometimes people add viscosity but this
is not important here let's let's look
at the invit form inv visit vergus
equation and then you have some initial
data which is a of X and that is chosen
from some measure mu which is a
probability measure on some functions
let's say L1 okay so this is a very very
simple setup and in fact in this
particular case our initial data was
chosen from what are called gaussian
random Fields So gausian Random fields
are a simple generalization to functions
of Brownian motion for instance or
something which is related to Brownian
motion so these are essentially noise so
you start with some sort of colored
noise some structure of noise scou and
random Fields but that is just to give
you a concrete numerical example other
examples will work equally equally well
so you start with gaan random Fields as
initial data and then you let the
solution evolve at a later time so let's
say that it what happens at t equal to 1
so typically a function with a gausian
random field might have the following
shape something it would look something
like this okay that would be a typical
example of a gausian random field now
you put it into the nonlinearity and
what the nonlinearity does for those who
come from fluid mechanics this is
obvious that this is going to sort of
steepen the steepen the structures so
because of that after a while if you
have a initial data like this these
little noise structures will clear out
and you'll get the formation of what are
called Shock waves sharp fronts right so
this is what happens for instance when
the aircraft is flying across the Sonic
line faster than the speed of sound the
sound waves that are coming out they
they sort of breach the sound barrier
and create shock waves okay and this is
uh how the solution looks like the
solution is in Orange as you can see the
ground truth which is generated by
numerical method but now we use leonet
uh with I don't remember how many
samples for training maybe around a
thousand I really don't remember this
and then you can start seeing what the
problem is right so of course it
provides you some answer but several
things are wrong it does not get the
right uh position of these
discontinuities and of course once it
does not get the right position it does
not get the right amplitud ude and in
this particular case the error is very
large it's like 30% the relative error
but it's the the percentage is not as
important as what you see on the picture
right where sometimes 30% is acceptable
if the problem is very hard but this is
a very simple problem and this is a lot
of Errors so clearly somewhere even
though all these nice structure
preserving properties are satisfied
something is going on otherwise uh we
would have solved the problem and this
was somehow answered a little bit
because now we compare it with fno o
right because fno o does not have the
structure preserving property that
doesn't mean the structure preservation
is bad but it's just one dimension one
one metric along which you evaluate
things so for instance there is some
Theory from my lab what we do is that we
compare the two theoretically a very
very simple
problem the same can be done for burgers
equation also so if you take linear
Direction so this will be UT plus ux c =
z and you know what the solution is
going to be right so U of is U not the
initial data minus CT right so for
instance if you start with a bump like
this you just transport it right and you
start with a slightly different bump you
transport it to the same location but uh
just the shape is different it depends
on the initial data so one could prove
in this case rigorously mathematically
that in principle assuming that you can
train perfectly which is never the case
but even under the assumption that you
can train perfectly to get an error of a
certain uh magnitude Epsilon in this
particular case with a Depot net you
need uh it's quadratic in the in the
sort of in the error so to get 1% error
which is 1 over 100 you need the let's
say the number of parameters the size is
like 10,000 it's just a rough
calculation right it's there are some
constants here but say it's of the order
of 10,000 it's nothing but that that's
that's the number but if no for the same
problem you can prove rigorously that it
scales like a logarithm so it is not let
alone being linear it's it's not like
you need 100 you need 10 you need log of
100 so this is a rigorous proof which
says that for solving exactly the same
problem albe it a very academic problem
for fno you need something which is
logarithmic in complexity and for Depon
net you need something which is
quadratic in complexity so even if you
are trying to learn the basis and so on
and so forth it does not really pay off
with respect to accuracy you preserve
some structure well and good but it does
not pay off in terms of accuracy because
you are far off from what you want to do
and this is also shown I think this is
for advection equation even for this
very simple problem you can see that
tonet gives you around 8% error whereas
F gives you one1 of that okay for the
same size you get one10 lesser of course
this theorem is what it is means it's a
it's a need theorem there are constants
and it's difficult to evaluate the
constants and so this tells you that
it's only a part of the story to
preserve the structure mean f also has
its own advantages and by sort of
putting everything into one fixed basis
or un learnable basis you don't really
solve the problem because some of the
Vital Information is lost and this is
the reason why DEET actually does very
very poor in practice so here is an
example of uh
here the same problem that we have seen
before so this is the ground truth and
this is the prediction of fno which is a
fairly reasonable prediction there are
as you can see there is some
interference here there is some issue
here so the error I think with fno was
like 4% I don't remember you'll see it
in the next lecture and uh CNN this is
unet the one that we had seen before you
see that there is this aliasing but it
also did does a reasonable job and look
at what happened to tonet it just
predicted the average over the entire
sample so it simply does not have the
performance so this is in this
particular case it's 12 or 15% but it
simply did not work uh in any reasonable
way and this is primarily because of
course there is some theorem which tells
you what's going wrong but intuitively
what is happening is that we are losing
some structure of the problem by somehow
putting it back into just one fixed set
of parameters which is precisely the
point that you said right what is the
difference in terms of parameters uh in
some sense there is no there is a little
bit of a difference but morally you're
doing the same you're not really keeping
the sort of infinite dimensional
structure you're solving one problem but
you are creating another that you lose
the expressivity so the challenge very
much remains which is that we need to
design something that really works and I
would say it's still a
challenge we have not solved this by any
means but in the next lecture I'll start
showing you architectures which go
further in this direction that they
preserve the structure while at the same
time they also work but it's also
important to know what are the things
that are out there and what works and
what doesn't work so this was sort of
the main objective today okay so let's
stop here we are almost on time which is
rity but uh and then we next week we we
continue with this this theme further